long before the massive explosion that
tore into beirut last august
lebanon had been following a path that
led only one way
to self-destruction as the smoke rose
over the city around 200 people
lay dead and thousands have been injured
victims of corrupt and incompetent
politicians
who for generations had allowed their
citizens to sink
into poverty and despair
the explosion was a terrible symbol of
that neglect
the cause a highly volatile quantity of
ammonium nitrate
that had sat for years in a warehouse
while port officials warned of the
danger it posed
warnings that were systematically
ignored
but would anything change in the
aftermath would anyone
ever be held to account foreign sympathy
arrived in the shape of france's emanuel
macron
only he brought an uncompromising
message there's no blank
check he told people if your political
class fails
we won't come to lebanon's aid and
fail it did days later the government
resigned
not only did the politicians have no
answers they had like so many before
them
simply given up who would now fill the
[Music]
vacuum
[Music]
hello and welcome to this special
edition of conflict zone
over the last four years we've
interviewed several senior lebanese
politicians
about the inexorable breakdown of their
economy and their state institutions
what they told us provides an unusually
clear insight into the reasons for
lebanon's intractable crisis
we sought answers to some key questions
what had gone wrong
who was to blame for the sinking economy
and how could the country move forward
but instead of answers we got promises
of progress of clarity and commitment
even transparency that in most cases
came to nothing
in february 2016 i caught up with gibran
basil
then the country's foreign minister who
acknowledged the central feature
of lebanese politics endemic corruption
as well as all the other contradictions
that have made it impossible
for the state to function yes we have
corruption in our country
but this is why we need to have strong
leaders to fight corruption corruption
and different factions playing politics
yes
with a nation that can ill afford it i
mean even the patriarch spoke of the
erosion of your state institutions at
the moment
as of course so you're collapsing the
states collapsing
it depends how you how you define the
collapse
we still have at least a family in
lebanon we still have values
values of how we live how we think
towards the other
where this is fading completely in other
parts
even in strong and prosperous countries
you don't see this kind of cohesion that
we still have in lebanon
cohesion you failed to get a president
in two years what cohesion
is that almost 35 attempts to get a
quorum in parliament
you haven't managed to do it you haven't
passed a budget since 2005.
you have a parliament whose mandate ran
out in 2013 and had to extend it twice
without recourse to the public you
haven't had legislative elections since
2009.
yes everywhere again this is complete
paralysis of the political body
isn't it and we are against all this but
well you're not doing much about it
i'm not defending against it i'm not
defending the politics in lebanon the
politicians
nor the minister
i'm defending something that belongs to
all of us in humanity i'm defending
the idea and the model that we still
represent
of diversity of living together of
accepting
each other where we are different this
is what i'm defending and this is where
i'm seeing the importance of lebanon
if we have this model versus the model
of daesh what do you choose
you choose the raqqa model with daesh or
you still have lebanon
where people can still live together
because what else can you get
so you can get the dash model minister
how much of this living together was
apparent when
you see the people protest on the
streets of lebanon as they have done
over the last
year and they get uh subjected to
unacceptable violence by the security
services
water cannon tear gas
rubber bullets you know i was among the
protesters
levels of violence i went myself to the
street because i refuse this situation
so who's in charge in this government
who's in charge we are we are
in jail there in jail of power because
we cannot leave again
you're a government that doesn't control
your security services is that what
you're telling me no
still even with the security level we
are still fine if we compare us to
other regions other countries around us
in the region
so again it is a situation that we have
to fix
how by not imposing a
a solution that is a ready solution a
ready recipe
by allowing the lebanese let let them go
to elections and allow them to truly
haven't had elections we pointed out
since 2009. and we were against this
we we i'm confused because because your
prime minister
said the levels of force used against
demonstrators was
unacceptable he's the prime minister
can't he do anything about this
yes he stopped it but how did he start
who was
prosecuted i'm telling you i was
prosecuted i was myself on the street no
but who was prosecuted
three times for the excesses because i
refused the situation
minister you refused the situation but
people got beaten up people got
hospitalized
dozens of people were taken to the
hospital people were injured
on the streets let's not portray lebanon
as a country where you
you don't allow people to express
themselves we have an excess of
democracy in
lebanon people are allowed to speak out
whatever your security organizations are
out of this culture
this happened again lebanon the bacon of
uh of freedoms in the region and this
happened once we don't
take this incident and extrapolated on
our
minister daily life how can you claim to
be a beacon of freedom
when the allegations of torture carried
out by your security services
are widespread june last year there was
a leaked video showing members of your
internal security forces
torturing inmates in rumia prison north
of beirut the interior minister
confirmed that the video was authentic
this is the kind of beacon of tolerance
and coexistence that you say you have
where torture is widespread
human rights watch said this was just
the tip of the iceberg exception
that confirms the rule
no we don't have this coming this is an
incident that happened
there if you say that this is what
happened in guantanamo
does it mean that in the u.s you live
the torture
this is an incident that happened once
and that
confirmed that well this is not the case
in lebanon you know
because it is we have so many things
that we are not satisfied about 11 but
we don't turn it into being a place
where people are tortured and yet the
reports credible reports of torture
have continued to surface in the four
years since that interview was recorded
no change there no change either in any
of the sectarian carve-ups and political
patronage
that have acted and still act as
immovable roadblocks to reform
ever since the civil war the complex
power sharing system
spawned many factions and warlords who
empowered and enriched themselves at the
expense of the people
they shared between them the spoils the
top jobs the lucrative contracts
and even as they watched the country
disintegrate and default
the last thing they wanted was to give
back the money and relinquish their
power
in june this year the combative foreign
minister at the time nasif hitti
was still repeating the same vague
assurances and the same good intentions
that have consistently led nowhere
i hear intentions your public sector
has been looted for decades by the same
sectarian powers
that still dominate this is what you're
trying to say
you never allow me to finish the phrase
so i'm listening to you now you go tell
me what you should do
perhaps we can profit from you i haven't
finished the question you think these
warlords and power brokers but you're
never letting me finish the answer
you've been giving me a great answer for
a couple of minutes do you think
do you think these warlords and power
brokers who control so much in lebanon
will just sit around while you shine a
light on all their dirty dealings
and then they'll just say sorry and hand
back all the billions that they've
stolen you really think that's gonna
happen
we are not gonna think so thanks for
putting this question
we know it's an uphill struggle we know
it's a key challenge and you have to
stand up to the challenge or fail
i know the difficulties i fully agree
with you about the seriousness of the
challenges
about how heavily they are weighing on
us since years
but we have to come out with an answer
otherwise we will not be taken
the road that we promised to take that's
a very important matter i fully agree
about the challenges the nature of the
challenges
the magnitude of the challenges but you
have to come out with an answer to these
challenges
and create a sort of rapture with the
past and get on a
start on a new uh foot your your
country's record doesn't inspire
confidence does it since the civil war
lebanon has promised four times to
reform in return for
about the future if foreign want to go
into the past you can have a lesson in
history now
yeah but why should anyone i'm trying to
tell you we know the stories we learn
the lessons we're trying
and we're telling the international
community look at look at us and let's
see
if we succeed we are we are planning to
succeed
we are committed to success because we
have to save our country
again i agree with you about your
description of the situation which i
already know we all we all know
and again i'm saying it's a major
challenge let's see
for you if you could succeed in facing
up to it
and this is the challenge that you are
taking on us
is to succeed this matter with the
cooperation it's our prime
responsibility
as lebanese government it's not an easy
matter i fully agree with you it's a
very difficult matter
because of this well-established
well-entrenched
system that you rightly described and
with which i fully agree with you
but this is the only road that you have
to take to create
a rupture of the past the challenges are
very important
very deep but we have to take this is
the only available road to get out of
this messy
situation but two months later mr hitti
took his own road and resigned
contradicting all the firm assurances
he'd given in the interview
and declaring that the government he'd
so briefly served had shown
a lack of will to reform of course it
had
to many lebanese the system had long
since passed the point where it could be
effectively reformed it now needed to be
replaced
from top to bottom but how to convince
the power brokers of that
even the slow motion collapse of the
state signposted so
often and in so many ways still wasn't
enough to persuade them
that the old game was finally ending
your prime minister warned last year
that lebanon risked becoming a
failing state even the most basic
services now don't get provided to your
people how did you let
get so bad i wouldn't call lebanon a
failed state when he was able to cope
with
50 percent of his population as refugees
200
syrian displaced to lebanon per square
kilometer
and that he said last october i warn we
are moving towards collapse
if matters continue yeah but when when
solid states and successful states like
in europe were not able to receive
more than ten thousand refugees and
lebanon
got adapted with one and a half million
i wouldn't we have a very successful
model
that if it fails our model of diversity
and
coexistence then everything will fail
and minister it's not successful when
you can't even
cope with the rubbish on the streets you
can't even clear the rubbish you can't
blame the refugees for that
can you no but this is this is our
responsibility
i cannot deny it but still this is a
system that has become the activists say
so
inefficient and corrupt that it can't
provide basic services
it depends how you measure the success
of a society you can have a democracy
and the prosperity but no cohesion and a
society
so everything gets disintegrated but a
society that can't clear the rubbish and
can't clear
the air for its people and puts their
health in danger
shouldn't be governing [ __ ] i i'm not
defending this but i'm i'm saying you
have also
political garbage and you have the war
garbage that you are witnessing
everywhere and i think this is
still less costly than having dealing
people as garbage and killing them
like when we have two hundred thousand
uh killed per people
in uh in syria and in the region we are
enforcing it i understand but a
government that cannot provide
basic services isn't worthy of the name
of a government is it
why don't you resign because find
somebody who can clear the right you are
you are right on this but
the problem is that we have vacancy but
you don't resign you stay there we
cannot resign
we are obliged to stay because there
will be no government
there will be complete void in lebanon
if we resign
stay and gamble with the health of your
people no no
we should elect a president who should
be representative of his people a strong
president with strong
popularity and then we will have another
government instead there are feuds
infighting manipulation and you say this
is a model of cooperation
this is a model of coexistence this is a
model of political paralysis
isn't it yes it is so so what about this
cooperation political paralysis i'm not
talking of cooperation i'm talking of
co-existence because
in lebanon somehow muslims and
christians are still living together in
a power sharing model
in parity where this does not exist
anywhere else in the world and
sunnis and shias despite all the tension
around us
are still not fighting in lebanon and
there's no leadership and there's no
decisions
yes this is from under the central bank
this is
kind also of the paralysis that we have
in the whole region because
in lebanon it is somehow reflected in
politics this
this will of eliminating the other but
you're to blame you're part of this
system you're part of the system that is
broken down completely i'm not there
denying our
our global and collective responsibility
last october thousands of demonstrators
angry and frightened
called for an end to political
corruption and for a new
untainted set of politicians to run the
country
they toppled two administrations in
rapid succession
the protest movement cut across
religious and political lines
with demands for the recovery of stolen
funds and for the corrupt to be held
accountable
and there was plenty to account for
years of squalor in the streets as
politicians
bickered over garbage collection
contracts and electricity failed for
hours on end
month after month among those being
called out for criticism
was the hezbollah movement the
self-styled party of god
financed by iran and they didn't like it
let's talk about the massive street
protests that we've seen in lebanon in
recent months
one moment you seem to be listening to
them then you claimed with no evidence
that they were being exploited by the us
and israel and then last october you
sent your thugs to beat up the
demonstrations
because they dared to criticize your
leaders absolutely not
absolutely not i'm not i'm sorry i'm
sorry tim i don't
i don't know you like that i mean i
don't know that are you sure that we
send our people do you have a proof
it was widely reported at the time we
were against that
in october and december widely you know
the media issue
you're in the media i mean the media
this is the missing information there
yeah we don't make it out well i can't
tell you i
i live mr musa we don't make it up i'm
around i
i live here and i tell you i i tell you
we're not part of those who suppress the
people we are with the masses we are
with those who demonstrated
we want to protect them we have the same
issue actually we consider
mr musawi in december your supporters
attacked an anti-government protest camp
in central beirut
and the army had to be called in to
disperse the groups
around the same time you and your allies
from amal targeted
other anti-government protest camps in
different parts of lebanon
so much for listening to the
demonstrators and heeding their demands
you beat them up
i can simply say this is not true well
hezbollah whether you like it or dislike
it represents a large component of dubai
society it's a main
political party political actor in
lebanon and everybody
is welcome to join and help us and this
whether directly being involved directly
or supportive or not supportive of the
government
let's see for the observers internal
observers
and external observers like you sir if
you succeed you
you say this and i hear what you say why
should the west
lift a finger to help a government
that's effectively being constructed by
hezbollah
which is widely viewed around the world
it's not absolute reality hezbollah is
widely seen around the world as a
terrorist
organization it is not seen around the
world
it's considered by some but it is not
what this some
i don't agree with this view you might
disagree ideologically politically
strategically with the lebanese
political party libya's national
resistance movement that's your right to
do so
but it's a major represent a major
component of the lebanese society social
component and political component
what i'm saying take us to test as a
government i'm
telling our western countries with to
which we are committed to develop the
best out of relations
culturally politically socially
economically strategically with the
western countries
very close to most of those countries we
have very good relations which we want
to develop
to deepen strengthen and enlarge these
western countries
take us to test and about what we are
doing what you are planning to do
not in about what is said here or there
or about any ideological slogneering or
ideological
views according to the drug enforcement
agency
hezbollah increasingly relies on
criminal revenue
from a wide array of sources that
include the lebanese diaspora group
members affiliates
etc the organization has even competed
for money laundering contracts
in the same manner as colombian drug
cartels and other criminal organizations
so you belong with some shady groups
on the international crime scene don't
you you can
you can continue to mention all if you
want to continue this episode as long as
you want you can continue to mention as
much as you want of examples but this is
not going to change the truth
that these are things are put in the
mouth of the
western media against hezbollah against
any
resistance movement against any
resistance group in order to distort its
its image in order to justify any
sanctions against it
you asked for examples i gave you some
let's talk if we may
about um your support for the assad
government bashar al-assad in syria
despite its shocking disregard for human
life especially
civilians you could hardly claim
ignorance of what they've been doing or
don't you the
party of god have anything to say about
policies of rape
torture and extermination that bashar
al-assad and his
forces have been carrying out you've got
no principles no red lines as far as
that sort of behavior is concerned
the let me ask you about the western
media and about your government and the
western governments and the united
states governments and what they did to
the israelis who crash the people
every day who occupy palestine who
occupy parts of lebanon who occupy parts
of
the gulen heights and who continue to
occupy
also they want to and next part of
jordan and
parts of uh of other places i mean
we ask those questions in other programs
i'm talking to you about hezbollah
i'm talking to you about hezbollah
because you represent hezbollah and i'm
asking
why you support why you support us
in syria that will defend carries out
extermination policies towards its own
people we're supporting our cause we're
we're fighting
listen we we're we're we were fighting
takfiri groups
who beheaded people who took the hearts
of people who crossed the who crushed
the
the children who made annihilation this
is we were fighting the takfiri groups
it is a priority because they came and
they uh
carried aggressions against our part of
the country you know we had
wide operations against them in north
lebanon in east lebanon
mr the important thing is that by
lending
mr assad your support you became
complicit
in everything he did and these are
crimes
against humanity the u.n high
commissioner for human rights
and you are complicit with with muhammad
bin salman all and all the atrocities he
is making in yemen
uh united states and britain and all
governments you are complicit
so it's the west's fault along with
everyone else's lots of blame to be
shared around
so much in fact that it doesn't actually
stick to anyone
the parties take responsibility in name
only
and they stay in their posts whatever
mistakes or crimes they've committed
it's a system of accountability but with
zero consequences
except of course for the people who have
to live with all the criminality
and incompetence poverty and now hunger
small wonder that their patience is
close to exhausted
how long do you expect the people to
wait for these rights that you're
promising
these reforms that you're promising the
end to
back our corruption money give us back
our looted money
this is what they say when are the
people of lebanon going to get back
we are very much we are very much aware
and committed to that it's not that
government that looted the money
before it's not this government that
created the situation
that was before but however we are
committed to do
all what we can with our friends again
saying inside and outside reaching to
everybody
in order to get out of this vicious
destructive circle that lebanon found
itself
in i understand the very legitimate
frustration as well
as the very legitimate demands of the
lebanese population of which
i'm a member i'm a lebanese citizen
before being a lebanese official we
understand these problems
we have to get together and try to get
out of this
very difficult situation at least we
have the commitment and the clarity
that we need to get out of this
difficult situation
so i ask where are the reforms why
aren't you pushing for them
you blame the system i'm asking talking
about what's the point of having you in
government
if you don't bring about reforms the
ailments i'm talking
i'm talking about the ailments of the
system that has been gone
going on for so many years i mean for
decades
now we have reached where we reached we
should be held responsible for what
happened everybody is responsible
those who were in the government we are
part of the government we don't deny our
responsibility we have to embrace our
full responsibility in this
and we're ready to take part in the
response responsibility
but still when you talk about the kind
of
reforms that we want to do they should
be structural we are one component
of the mosaic of components and
constituencies in the lebanese society
we take our share and others has to take
their responsibilities
and they should be blamed for what they
did if even just a few of those
comforting words from our politicians
had been turned into action then lebanon
might look very different from the way
it does today
but no single political figure or
faction appears to have the authority to
bring about fundamental change
and there's little chance of the
different groups agreeing on a single
course of action
as for the people many say they'd leave
if they could
food prices have skyrocketed
unemployment is rife
the banks have severely limited access
to savings
for now two important questions hang
unanswered over lebanon
can the cash-strapped west afford to
give it the emergency support it needs
and in a highly volatile region like
this with conflict
never far from the surface can it really
afford
not to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you